trois hommes exécutés en public en chine
et la répression terrible et immédiate
indignation générale dans le monde
rebondissement dans l'affairé luchaire
le procureur général bézard laisse
entendre que les hommes politiques ont
étouffé la sphère la trouille ou le trac
pour 480 mille élèves de terminale
demain les épreuves principales bac
commandes
la france qui chante et qui danse ce
soir à chaque coin de rue c'est l'été et
la fête de la musique c'est la huitième
bonsoir l'horreur en chine en un mois
juste le gouvernement chinois a exercé
la répression la plus terrible sur le
grand élan de démocratie qui avait agité
le pays
l'horreur aujourd'hui avec cette
information trois hommes ont été
exécutés en public à shanghai une balle
dans la nuque pour deux ouvriers et un
chômeur qui avait été à l'origine de
l'incendié d'un train au cours des
manifestations
lorsqu'on sait que huit autres condamnés
à mort attendent d'être exécutés et que
1700 chinois vont être traduits en
justice
on mesure l'ampleur effrayante de cette
répression
bruno le drudge propagande oblige c'est
lors du journal télévisé que les chinois
ont appris les exécutions de shanghai
deux ouvriers un sommer condamné à mort
pour rébellion contre révolutionnaire
ils ont été abattus l'un après l'autre
conformément à l' usage en chine d'une
balle dans la nuque une balle qui sera
facturé à leurs familles
l'exécution s'est déroulée en public
face à 3000 personnes
un événement qualifié d'ordinaire par le
porte parole du tribunal qui a précisé
que des tracts décrivant les crimes des
trois coupables avaient été distribués à
la foule à des fins éducatives
en fait les trois hommes étaient accusés
d'avoir incendié ce train à shanghai le
4 juin dernier lors d'une manifestation
qui avait réuni plusieurs milliers de
personnes
en rendant son verdict le tribunal avait
fait valoir que les destructions de
matériels de transport constituait un
crime d'une extrême gravité réprobation
unanime dans le monde entier dans tous
les pays on se dit scandalisé par cvc
exécution et on s'indigne de la
répression pratiquée par le gouvernement
chinois
en revanche on annonce pour l'instant
aucune mesure concrète aucune sanction
par exemple les états unis regrettent
profondément les exécutions mais ont
décidé de ne prendre aucune nouvelle
sanction pour l'instant en france même
indignation de tous côtés
le président mitterrand a lancé il ya
quelques minutes un appel solennel aux
autorités chinoises pour qu'elles
fassent preuve de clémence à l'égard des
autres personnes condamnées à la peine
capitale à l'assemblée nationale
on a tout à l'heure observé une minute
de silence et puis écouter ensuite ce
qu'a dit le ministre des affaires
étrangères roland dumas
les nouvelles les plus récentes des
premières exécutions montrent que la
machine totalitaire dans toute son
horreur est en marche
les circonstances de ces exécutions en
jeu ajoute encore à l'horreur et le fond
de ce qui pourrait être d exécution de
décisions de justice de véritable
assassinat
la france a lancé un appel à la clémence
avec ses partenaires de la communauté
européenne
je suis au désespoir de dire que cet
appel n'a pas été entendu
les autorités chinoises se mettent donc
elle même au ban de la communauté des
nations
voilà alors au delà des exécutions des
pardons des réactions indignées mais
souvent assez molle d'ailleurs dans le
monde entier on l'a vu tout à l'heure
avec les réactions américaines par
exemple oui à la réaction il y à ce qu'a
fait part dans le gouvernement chinois
alors bruno ledreck vous étiez en chine
pour nous notre envoyé spécial au cours
de ces dernières semaines et bruno le
gouvernement chinois a décidé de frapper
très fort
oui le gouvernement chinois veut
visiblement faire aujourd'hui passer un
double message tout d'abord à usage
interne il s'agit de faire savoir aux
opposants qu'ils n'ont aucune clémence à
espérer et ensuite il doit être clair
pour les pays étrangers que la chine
n'acceptera aucune ingérence dans ses
affaires intérieures
cela quelles que soient les
protestations des pays occidentaux
les chinois n'en tiendrons aucun qu'ont
ils ont écrasé dans le sang le mouvement
étudiant devant des centaines de
journalistes devant des centaines de
témoins et cela ne les a à aucun moment
où la vue empêcher d'agir en période de
crise la chine a d'ailleurs toujours
tendance à se replier sur elle-même il
ya quelques jours à pékin j'ai vu
ressurgir des banderoles clamant des
slogans qui datait de la révolution
culturelle du slogan sur la capacité du
pays à vivre et à se développer sans
l'aide de l'extérieur
le message est clair alors bruno
aujourd'hui ce sont deux ouvriers et un
chômeur qui ont été exécutés ce n'est
pas du tout un hasard non en effet alors
que de nombreux étudiants ont été
arrêtés aucun ne figure pour l'instant
parmi les condamnés à mort le
gouvernement chinois a agi comme s'il
voulait faire des exemples à travers la
seule population civile il faut
d'ailleurs savoir que les étudiants
chinois sont très peu nombreux 2
millions pour une population de plus
d'un milliard d'habitants ce sont les
futurs cadres de la chine et ils sont
d'ailleurs les enfants des cadres
actuels du pays
un seul exemple où rkf il a des leaders
du mouvement étudiant est le fils d'un
membre important du parti communiste
chinois
il serait donc étonnant qu'à quelques
rares exceptions près les étudiants
paient de leur vie leur désir de
démocratie et de liberté des hommes et
des femmes
d'ailleurs on l'a vu prix plus ou moins
au hasard parmi les classes populaires
qui se sont massivement joints aux
étudiants font donc aujourd'hui de
parfaits boucs émissaires merci bruno en
france à peine les élections terminées
la face cachée de la politique ressurgit
des affaires pas très propre qui remonte
à la surface brusquement avec des
relents de règlements de comptes
première histoire la sphère lüscher
vendredi dernier nous étions les
premiers à vous annoncer que le juge
avait prononcé un non lieu dans cette
affaire lüscher cette affaire de vente
illégale d'armes à l'iran rebondissement
aujourd'hui avec des propos du procureur
de la république hier bizarre l'idée
générale d'après le procureur sait que
les hommes politiques ou étouffer ce
dossier c'est tout le problème de la
séparation des pouvoirs entre le pouvoir
politique et pouvoir judiciaire qui est
posée c'est aussi le problème de
certains sujets comme les ventes d'armes
qui sont toujours tabou en france
explications d'hervé bosnie
sur le front politique là car elle
faisait rage cet après midi au coeur des
escarmouches la sphère luchet hypocrisie
double jeu lancé le député rpr jacques
toux maux à l'adresse du gouvernement
vous nous présenter un projet de
moralisation du financement de la vie
politique au moment même où vous
demandez et vous obtenez le placement de
la paire lüscher alors pourquoi avoir
classé la sphère interrogé tine réplique
de pierre joxe
vous avez voulu monter une machination
elle est tombée à plat querelles encore
sur le fond judiciaire cette fois les
couloirs du palais justice prenait des
allures de trancher ici c'est un article
de presse qui a mis le feu aux poudres
dans un entretien accordé à l'est
républicain
le procureur de paris pierre bédard
affirme que la sphère lüscher a été
monté par les politiques et étouffé par
eux
conformément à la loi j'ai obéi à ma
hiérarchie déclare en substance le
magistrat quelques heures plus tard
qu'hier bézard rectifie communiqué
officiel où il affirme que ses décisions
étaient pleinement justifiés que le
travail du juge ne pouvait plus
progresser en un mot pour le procureur
de paris le grand coupable dans tout
cela ce n'est pas la justice
mais la politique et le garder chaud
renchérit ce soir sur le même terrain il
y a eu un blocage non pas par ce
gouvernement non pas de la faute de ce
pouvoir
mais il faut remonter à novembre 1987 à
mon avis lorsque le juge d'instruction a
demandé au prédécesseur de monsieur
chevènement de lui envoyer certains
documents et cette fois la querelle se
fait à proprement parler militaire cette
question des documents
c'est andré giraud qu'elle vise à
l'époque où il était ministre de la
défense de jacques chirac
d'après le juge d'instruction jamais les
pièces déterminant du dossier en
l'occurrence les originaux des faux qui
ont servi à justifier l'exportation des
obus n'ont été communiquées par l'armée
ni avant ni après 88 d'ailleurs d'une
seule et même voix
l'ancien et l'actuel ministre de la
défense ont beau protester de leur
volonté de collaborer avec la justice
sur ce point la grande muette
evans est bien resté lui est autre
dossier qui ressort la sphère nakache
jacques chirac d'ailleurs l'avait évoqué
il ya huit une huitaine de jours en se
demandant s'il ne fallait pas libéré
anis naccache le terroriste pour ne pas
risquer de nouveaux attentats
prochainement bien ce matin au sénat
pierre joxe le ministre de l'intérieur a
interrogé son prédécesseur charles
pasqua à ce sujet pour monsieur pasqua
la meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
alors il a répliqué bernard trading il y
à moins d'une semaine monsieur chirac
demande au chef de l'état de réfléchir
sur la libération du terroriste
anis naccache aujourd'hui monsieur
pasqua enfonce le clou et accuse
monsieur dumas d'être à l'origine de
plusieurs attentats en france puis dit
que le gouvernement précédent avaient
pris des engagements pour les bérets
bleus nakache comme d'ailleurs pour
libérer le serbe l'a fait c'est en
particulier parce que ces engagements
n'ont pas été tenus que nous avons eu
une série d'attentats quant à nous nous
n'avons jamais pris aucun engagement ni
au sujet de monsieur nakache au sujet de
quelques autres terroristes que ce soit
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
georges répond par une question pourquoi
monsieur chirac crainte des attentats
pourquoi n'est-il pas plus explicite et
il demande à monsieur pasqua d'être
moins confus tout le monde sait que la
tâche a été arrêté après avoir commis un
crime et immédiatement il a été
poursuivi à ce titre est condamné
pourquoi est-ce que
monsieur pasqua devant le sénat mélangez
ça avec l'as far abdallah qui est tout à
fait différente et il a prêté à nakache
des éléments de la sphère abdallah
pourquoi est ce que c'est parce qu'il
confond ses souvenirs
est ce parce qu'ils vous confondre les
autres est une chose qui devra expliquer
à ce sujet parce qu'elle est énigmatique
ce soir dans un communiqué le ministre
des affaires étrangères monsieur dumas
refuse je cite de polémiquer sur un
sujet trop sérieux monsieur pasqua
ajoute-t-il affabule pour sortir
monsieur chirac d'un mauvais pas où il
s'est mis lui même pour des raisons
ténébreuse à l'instant même je prends
connaissance des réquisitions dans le
procès de la branche lyonnaise d'action
directe le proc l'avocat général pardon
du procès a requis tout à l'heure la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté de 18 ans
contre andré olivier et maxime frérot le
grand frisson pour 480 mille élèves de
terminale c'est demain avec le début des
grosses épreuves du bac qu'il y a déjà
eu le français lundi pour les élèves de
première et puis le bac technique ces
jours ci mais demain c'est le gros
morceau
l'organisation du bac chaque année c'est
un scénario qui frise la catastrophe
pas facile à mettre en place enquête
chantal kimmerlin et philippe gas b
derrière ses fenêtres c'est l'enfer du
bail la maison ne répond plus à
l'intérieur on prépare des milliers de
sujets on attend 10 millions de copies
il faut surveiller corrigé examiné
convoqué répartir c'est l'effondrement
des prisonnières et crises de larmes de
l'hypotension d hypertension de respect
de ma fille
après trente à quarante deux personnes
par jour seront bien sûr 300 personnes
un service public qui ne peut plus
répondre à la demande 35 mille candidats
de plus cette année des bacs de plus en
plus spécialisés des nouvelles options
théâtre cinéma audiovisuel pour quelques
400 candidats certaines comme le
géorgien le tamoul ou le bambara pour un
seul candidat
guère plus je vous demande de pause pour
le tamoul s'avérer pour pour wii 213 les
bts alors il va figer la comptabilité
cette équation d'actions commerciales
331 contestation aussi tout le temps il
conteste quand ils sont pas reçus et
même quand il sortit alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on vous appelle en gros au
pour des bêtises
le chien langer la convocation maman l'a
lavé en production matérielle c'est
aussi le stress plus de 12 millions de
sujets sont passés sur ses rotatives
pour ce seul mois de juin
on a pris mais encore aujourd'hui à 14h
hypertrophie à tous les étages
l'entreprise bac devient précaire depuis
plusieurs années une épée de damoclès
menace à terme ce grand examen national
demain le bac assurément aura lieu mais
de justesse
demain cette même maison devra répondre
à un autre problème au manque de
professeurs pour corriger les copies
et puis n'oubliez surtout pas quand n 2
vous propose tous les corrigés du bac du
bac technique et du brevet c'est très
facile c'est sur minitel alors vous
composez simplement 36 15 codes apos
menaces sur les sur les départs de
vacances les départs en vacances dans le
trafic aérien
les pilotes de ligne pourrait bien se
mettre en grève le 1er juillet ils
veulent organiser un mouvement pour
attirer l'attention sur les problèmes de
recrutement des pilotes
c'est vrai que ces dernières années il
ya eu un boum du trafic aérien ça on le
sait et le recrutement est peut-être
aussi la formation des pilotes n'ont pas
forcément suivi alain daubé ski des
mains un peu crispé sur le manche
normal un stagiaire est aux commandes du
biréacteur
actuellement ils se succèdent dans les
simulateurs de vol pendant toute la
crise pétrolière les compagnies n'ont
pas embauché en aujourd'hui le trafic
aérien prend un essor considérable du
manque de pilotes
en particulier pour les compagnies
régionales elle éprouve des difficultés
de recrutement
oui ça devient de plus en plus difficile
mais je dirais que quand on les a
trouvés notre vrai problème ensuite de
les garder
pourquoi parceque ils ont tendance à
être aspirés par les grandes compagnies
qui offrent des profils de carrière et
des machines considérées par les
navigants et c'est normal comme plus
intéressante
la compagnie tnt par exemple a créé son
propre centre de formation
elle recrute premièrement déjà niveau
bac + 2 la formation pour devenir pilote
professionnel capable de voler aux
instruments donc coûte 450 mille francs
trois ans d'études
c'est cher mais des facilités sont
proposés actuellement nous avons versé
10 % de mon temps du stage alors le
reste est le reste est financé par la
banque comptera taponier qui vous sert
de caution
donc c'est la tat qui nous fait
regretter fonds sans que les charges de
quoi qu'en échange d'une promesse
embauche on consent cage à rester un
certain nombre d'années à l'attaqué
deuxième source de recrutement les
pilotes français qui faute d'emploi
étaient partis travailler à l'étranger
et gagner leur vie sur d'autres
continents en pilotant ce qu'il pouvait
aujourd'hui il faut les former aux jets
pour d'autres enfin c'est une
reconversion totale
j'ai fait le métier de stewart à la
suite de quoi j'ai fait une formation
complémentaire et je suis devenu ensuite
pilote a été hâtée les syndicats de
pilotes conteste ce type de formation il
a true insuffisante corporatisme eux
répondent les enseignants qui ajoute les
études proposées correspondent bien à la
nouvelle réglementation des brevets et
licences
on essaie de conserver justement la
qualité par rapport à la quantité qui a
demandé comment faites vous on va dire
sur les moyens pédagogiques et puis sur
un sérieux dangereux la formation des
instructeurs pour résorber le retard il
faudrait former 400 pilotes par an or
les écoles en propose que 350
de quoi expliquer la présence de puits
étrange et souvenirs et la grogne des
pilotes français une nouvelle
inculpation dans la sphère compte
boutboul
un homme de 47 ans françois chapleau a
été inculpé et écroué au havre par le
juge chargé de l'instruction sur le
meurtre de bruno d'assac un
rebondissement donc dans cette affaire
qui intervient 24 heures après le rejet
de mise en liberté de madame
compte-gouttes bull rémy roche wavre
deux jours après l'exécution de dassa qu
une demi douzaine de ses amis se
réunissent dans un appartement du à
l'histoire de faire le point de la
situation en quelque sorte
parmi eux un certain françois chapleau
la soixantaine bien connu des services
de police sans domicile ni profession
pics bien que dit-on il mène la grande
vie
chapleau est un intime de dassa et il
sait que dans l'appartement du défunt
il y à une mallette une mallette qu'il
va s'en passer de récupérer et
semble-t-il de faire disparaître
quel était son contenu pour l'instant
mystère mais le juge beaulieu qui
instruit le dossier la saq lui semble le
savoir
en tout cas ils considèrent que c'est
bien dommage que tout cela a disparu
puisqu'il vient d'inculper chapleau de
destruction de documents de nature à
faciliter la recherche des auteurs de
faits délictueux alors ça peut
reconnaît-il
le nom de l'assassin de la saxo verte et
trouble qui entretenait de bien étranges
rapport bien étrange relation avec
elisabeth france football
si oui il doit savoir aussi pourquoi
d'assac avait été condamné à mort et
j'apprends à l'instant dans cette
affaire toujours une deuxième
inculpation aujourd'hui celle de
l'ancienne amie de la victime
la victime s'était bruno da sac il
s'agit donc d'une infirmière de 42 ans
brigitte à miss elle vient d'être
inculpé mais elle a été laissée en
liberté
l'actualité internationale maintenant
avec les problèmes de gorbatchev en
union soviétique ce sont toujours les
mêmes d'ailleurs ce sont les troubles
dans un certain nombre de républiques et
notamment en asie après l'ouzbékistan le
kazakhstan où il y a eu quatre morts et
des dizaines de blessés le week-end
dernier
explications de georges bortoli sur
cette propagation de la violence en asie
centrale soviétique les sanglantes
émeutes de nos vies ou zen au kazakhstan
sont la suite malheureusement logique
des troubles non moins sanglant
d'ouzbékistan commencé en fin mai et des
manifestations au turkménistan haute
vu mes premières constatations l'armée
paraît relativement impuissante en
ouzbékistan douze mille hommes des
forces spéciales du ministère de
l'intérieur n'ont pas réussi vraiment à
protéger les populations victimes des
affrontements interethniques qu'il a
fallu purement et simplement évacués
deuxième constatation toutes les
populations concernées sont des
traditions musulmanes
c'est sans doute une des raisons pour
lesquelles monsieur rafsandjani qui
n'est pas encore président de la
république d'iran a été reçu à moscou
avec autant d'honneurs que s'il l'était
déjà
monsieur gorbatchev en ménageant les
autorités iraniennes espère notamment
qu'elles s'abstiendront d'exporter leur
propagande islamique vers l'asie
centrale soviétique déjà dangereusement
surchauffée en fait le drapeau vert le
drapeau de l'islam a déjà fait son
apparition au cours de certaines
manifestations récentes
la presse soviétique pour sa part
préfère insister sur les tensions
interethniques qui sont réelles les
populations réellement autochtones
s'entend assez mal avec des petits
groupes d'installation récentes souvent
des portes et du caucase sous staline
et puis il ya un autre facteur de
tension les conditions de vie par
exemple la ville pétrolière de nos vies
rosen manque d'eau tout simplement sans
parler du ravitaillement donc ces
violences sont aussi des émeutes de la
pénurie
le vietnam maintenant c'est un pays qui
s'ouvre de plus en plus aux relations
avec la communauté internationale en ce
moment même le chef de la diplomatie
vietnamienne est à paris
ça c'est l'ouverture diplomatique mais
il ya aussi l'ouverture économique que
l'on constate après les années de
repliement sur soi de ce pays après la
guerre du vietnam une ouverture
économique rendu absolument nécessaire
par le délabrement actuel du pays
jean-marc il use philipp etter reportage
au vietnam on n'a pas de piles mais on a
des idées
cette lampe de poche fonctionne avec une
dynamo huile de coude plus pérestroïka
voilà la recette du camarade lé kontan
ancien mineur ex maquisards toujours
communiste
mais aujourd'hui patron depuis juillet
son entreprise familiale est devenue une
entreprise privée de 200 personnes
employées dans une dizaine d'ateliers
comme celui-ci matériel début du siècle
mais bricolage de génie exemple ces
déchets de plastique proviennent de
vieux filets de pêche
une fois fondue ils serviront à faire
des joints étanches officiellement plus
question de brider les initiatives
commerciales au lieu d'un impôt de 15 %
sur les stocks
une taxe de 4 % sur les ventes
la moitié des quarante mille ans
produites annuellement sera exportée en
asie avec en gros un bénéfice de 15 %
mais sur le papier seulement car
salaires et profits sont instantanément
dévorée par l'inflation
puissant 900000 % l'inflation le prix
d'une journée de salaire pour un simple
vol de nuit comme celui ci où les
morceaux de porc de poulet ou de
crevettes se font de plus en plus peut y
voir de plus en plus rares c'est ce
processus d'appauvrissement général que
les réformistes du parti tente
désespérément d'enrayer pas question de
compter sur un coup de baguette magique
les institutions financières
internationales ne ferons rien tant que
l'armée vietnamienne n'aura pas
totalement évacué le cambodge
en attendant les partisans du changement
veulent pousser la carte de l'autonomie
de gestion comme dans cette fabrique de
chemine 2800 employés dirigée par une
équipe réduite de 18 cadre des cadres
qui désormais ne sont plus tenus à
chaque décision de quémander le feu vert
d'innombrables représentant du parquet
usine modèle bien entendu où les
ouvriers peuvent doubler leur salaire en
heures supplémentaires ou on travaille à
domicile
prochaine étape on pourra bientôt
exporter sans passer par l'organisme
d'état et peut-être même gérer une
partie des ressources en devises
une souplesse qui pour l'instant restent
l'exception explique le seul conseiller
non communistes du gouvernement
l'obstacle le plus important ça souvent
si je crois que c'est une machine
gouvernementale qui est très grande et
encombrantes et je suis en train ce
moment ci de le simplifier et de mettre
si vous voulez une espèce de gestion
business
une gestion qui est orienté sur le
marché
mais voilà l'évolution reste très lente
elle fait grincer bien des dents dans
l'appareil d'un parti qui n'acceptent
pas facilement le changement en dépit du
vote d'un code favorables aux
investisseurs étrangers
il n'a pas encore permis l'installation
vietnam d'une seule banque étrangère
river
mais pendant ce temps là des rivalités
ressurgissent entre certains pays du
bloc de l'est par exemple la roumanie
elle est en train de construire une
barrière de fils de fer barbelés à la
frontière hongroise
il s'agit pour les dirigeants roumains
de mettre un terme à l'exode des
citoyens roumains qui tentent de fuir la
dictature
voyons maintenant maintenant les autres
faits majeurs de l'actualité
internationale avec éric perrin
attentats déjoués en sicile contre le
juge antimafia falcon 50 kg d'explosifs
cachés dans un sac étanche ont été
découverts à 20 mètres seulement de la
villa du juge le plus protégé d'italie
falcon célèbre pour son action contre la
mafia serait le numéro un sur la liste
des condamnés à mort de la pieuvre
série de raids israéliens au sud de
beyrouth sur des positions du fplp cg
ahmad gibril organisations pro syrienne
dissidents de l'ol peut il y aurait eu
15 blessés parmi lesquels huit civils il
s'agit de la troisième attaque
israélienne contre des objectifs
palestiniens en une semaine
communiste grec contacté par les
conservateurs pour tenter de former une
coalition constantin mitsotakis chef du
parti de droite nouvelle démocratie tu
vainqueurs des législatives de dimanche
mais sans majorité absolue a proposé à
la coalition de la gauche et du progrès
de rentrer dans un gouvernement
provisoire chargé d'assainir la
situation politique
les communistes devraient donner leur
réponse demain et je reviens un court
instant sur les informations en
provenance de chine on vient de
l'apprendre mais nouvelles condamnations
à mort ont été prononcées tout à l'heure
à jinan dans le nord-est de la chine
dans cette ville 45 personnes étaient
jugées aujourd'hui certaines ont été
condamnés à mort on ne sait pas
exactement combien les autres ont été
condamnés à la prison ce sont donc les
ana les dernières informations en
provenance de chine
le sport maintenant déception pour les
basketteurs français pour leur deuxième
match dans le championnat d'europe en
yougoslavie les français ont été battus
par les grecs
malgré la victoire d'hier sur la
bulgarie ce sera très dur pour se
qualifier pour les demi finales de
samedi
claude et marc match important puisque à
la clé la qualification pour les
demi-finales de 7 euros 89 les grecs
sont favoris pourtant leurs supporters
sont un peu inquiet la france a réussi
hier une superbe performance
mais très vite sous l'impulsion de
galice le numéro 4 les tenant du titre
prennent le large
8en puis 13 points avance dans cette
première mi temps les français tentent
de réagir mais se montrent maladroits
malgré ce superbe panier de strauss qui
le meilleur français sur le terrain
c'est bien qu'à la mi temps les
supporters retrouvent leur voix la grèce
mène 40 2,33
en deuxième période les français
neutralisent galice et parviennent à
recoller au score grâce notamment à
quelques tirs à trois points de
dubuisson des paniers que les supporters
grecs préfèrent ne pas voir mais en fin
de match nouveau festival de galice les
grecs qui joue beaucoup mieux et
l'emportent finalement 80 74
dommage pour les basketteurs la fête de
la musique maintenant c'est ce soir dans
toute la france et même à l'étranger car
cette initiative de jacques landais
maurice fleuret fait maintenant tache
d'huile dans d'autres pays en tout cas
ce soir si vous désirez partout vous
vivrez au rythme du rock ou du folklore
c'est comme vous le sentez
depuis huit ans que la fête de la
musique a été instauré le succès ne
s'est jamais démenti cette année bien
sûr elle aura une connotation
révolutionnaire 89 oblige est l'un des
meilleurs musiciens martinique et c'est
henri guédon a créé une marseillaise
spéciale alors jean jacques dufour vous
êtes avec lui en direct jean jacques
oui bien tout de suite puisque c'est la
fête de la musique une introduction
musicale trois à quatre messieurs
anrig et dans vous la fête de la musique
vous l'a passé ici au studio campus a
répété avec musiciens le spectacle que
vous donnerez samedi 24 à bagneux dans
le parc robespierre et votre spectacle
s'intitule la marseillaise en trois
continents dit mme en deux mots c'est
une non c est ce qui fait l'afrique les
caraïbes les amériques et l'europe et
vous avez mangé toutes les musiques et
vous allez revisiter la morte et voilà
et ça va être joué un maillot cas en
calypso toutes les choses que bon vous
pouvez nous donner un petit aperçu ce
que j'allais donc tel xo en qualifs
selon mercy alors la marseillaise en
calypso à sac et les sacs et les sacs et
ni attaquer ni sakinis sakinis
et
didier
voilà alors ça c'était par exemple dans
un style
n'oubliez pas que ce soit de toute façon
sur antenne 2 à 22h25 nous aurons la
retransmission du concert de la bastille
en direct et pour finir avec une
nouvelle marseillaise mais cette fois en
mazurka une marseillaise avec un bazooka
piqué alors allons-y un chant
révolutionnaire encore une fois revisité
youri guaino même si je sais pas s'il
doit me élevé sur cette musique de
mazurka en tout cas je vous rappelle que
la fête de la musique s'est
partiellement bien sûr dans les studios
d'enregistrement ça c'était un peu
spécial c'est dans toute la france et un
peu partout dans toutes les villes et
d'ailleurs antenne 2 % rendra compte
voilà il est aussi sinon il n'y avait
pas intéressé il y en a 1 demain alors
voyons les pronostics que nous propose
qu'ils arrêtent brest et à longchamp et
le tir si je vous le rappelle à lui en
fin d'après midi à cause de la chaleur
le 4 le 8 le 16 le 10 est le 3 le 11
las et puis le 5 et à propos de chaleur
et bien la météo s'est tout de suite
avec laurent cabrol le dernier journal
henri sannier assez tôt vers 22h10 pour
cause de fête de la musique aussitôt
après télématin demain 6h45 bien sûr
avec un premier journal à cette heure
c'est marc hautement et catherine ceylac
et puis à 13h vous retrouverez comme
d'habitude patricia charnolé et william
leymergie excellente soirée sur antenne
2 à demain 20 heures